an early Christmas gift from the people
of Chester to the labor party as they
handed them an historic by-election win
last night securing 61 of the vote the
highest ever here while conservative
support collapsed to just 22 their worst
result since
1832. no wonder Labor's Deputy leader
was smiling happy baby what happened
here in Chester last night could have
consequences that reach far beyond this
city for labor they're now feeling more
confident than ever for conservative MPS
though looking at the size of this loss
some of them are now asking is it even
worth fighting the next general election
and just hours after the Chester Result
One senior figure revealed he won't be
Sajid Javid became the 13th Tory MP to
say he won't stand unlucky for Rishi
sunak to lose such a big name in British
politics serving for over a decade in
top jobs Home Secretary Chancellor and
health secretary back in July it was his
resignation that triggered the downfall
of Boris Johnson he then ran for a
second time to take over as leader
unsuccessfully before backing Liz truss
over his old Ally today the Prime
Minister put that aside to tweet his
sadness at the news adding a nod to
their friendship May the force be with
you Saj
there may be more to his departure than
last night's by-election result but
others will be carefully studying the
swing in Chester
13.8 percent Andy Carter is one MP who
should be worried he took Warrington
south from labor in 2019 with a slim
majority of Just 2 000 I asked him if
Sajid Javid standing down signaled the
beginning of the end there are other
things that you can do in life when you
come to the end of
um of of your career in in politics and
I quite understand that some people
might want to move on and do other
things really at the end of his career
though he's sort of in the middle and he
seems like he's lost faith in the
conservative party he's not the first
one of your colleagues to say that he
just he just won't stand in the next
general election why would you blame
them I think that's the interpretation
you can have I think there'll be many
people that look at the life of Politics
the life of Westminster I think I want
to do something else as well
back in Chester their Christmas message
to the conservatives has already been
delivered your time is up up Liz Bates
Sky News Chester